[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben heute machen wir den
saftigsten Gugelhupf der Welt
beziehungsweise den saftigsten
Marmorkuchen hört auf meine Worte seht
euch am Ende des Videos einfach das
Endergebnis an und macht es nach ihr
werdet sowas von überzeugt sein mein
Rezept ist auch so ausgelegt dass sie
einfach auch nur die Standard Zutaten
brauche ich also wenn ich so ein Rezept
jetzt mache und dann ist er auf einmal
noch im Joghurt hat man nicht immer da
aber ich habe extra ein Rezept für euch
wo ich sicher bin ja die Zutaten alle
daheim die Butter habe ich vorher aus
dem Kühlschrank genommen damit sie schön
Zimmer warm ist also sie ist schön weich
die gebe ich jetzt hier in meine
Rührschüssel und da gebe ich dann eine
Prise Salz die hebt nämlich noch mal den
süßen Geschmack gebe ich mit dazu Zucker
natürlich und Vanilleextrakt ist auch
ganz wichtig bei diesem Rezept und dann
lasse ich das Schlagen für so drei bis
vier Minuten mit meinem Rührhaken mit
der Gummilippe damit ich auch schön vom
Rand immer alles mitnehme
[Musik]
so nach zweieinhalb bis drei Minuten in
der Maschine ist die Masse schön fluffig
geworden und denkt an meine Worte beim
Vanilleextrakt nicht geizen ich weiß
auch meine Vanilleextrakt ist extrem
intensiv deswegen tue ich hier mal zwei
Teelöffel rein und nicht nur einen wie
ich sonst immer bei Rezepten mache aber
dieser Gugelhupf kann nur mit zwei
Dingen Punkten einerseits die saftige
Konsistenz und andererseits wenn ihr
eine saftige Konsistenz habt aber es
schmeckt halt nicht intensiv genug dann
ist es für mich auch kein perfekter
Google daher wenn Vanilleextrakt nicht
geizen so und jetzt gebe ich die Zimmer
beim Eier dazu es können auch kalte Eier
sein aber es ist einfach besser wenn die
eierzimmer warm sind für den Schritt
wechsel ich jetzt aber einmal hier das
Tool also da gebe ich jetzt den
schneebesenaufsatz dran weil das
verbindet sich dann einfach besser also
sowohl die Eier als auch später die
trockenen Zutaten verbinden sich dann
viel besser daher wechsel ich das jetzt
eben und dann gebe ich die Eier
durcheinander dazu und verrühre sie nur
so lange bis sie sich gerade so mit dem
Teig verbinden
[Musik]
Eier sind eingerührt wir machen weiter
mit den trockenen Zutaten und falls ihr
euch fragt wo stehen denn hier die
ganzen Zutaten die ganzen Angaben die
stehen unten in der Videobeschreibung
einfach unter dem Titel diese erweiterte
Box öffnen dann könnt ihr euch dann
nämlich ganz einfachen Screenshot machen
dann wird das Video nicht so langatmig
und wenn ihr das feiert das ist so ist
dass die Videos einfach auf den Punkt
kommen und trotzdem lehrreich sind dann
lass doch jetzt ein Abo da das würde
mich sehr freuen ich verrinne
Zwischenzeit hier einmal Speisestärke
mit mehl Speisestärke bring einfach noch
mal so eine das ist wieder ein saftiger
Google aber dennoch so ein leichte
Lockerheit mit rein ich weiß gar nicht
wie ich das beschreiben soll aber
vertrauten gibt Speisestärke mit dazu
solltet ihr gerade keine Speisestärke
daheim haben dann ersetzt die Menge
einfach durch Mehl so und jetzt kommt
noch Backpulver mit rein das ganze
sofort verrühren bei diesem Teig müsst
ihr die trockenen Zutaten nicht sieben
zumindest jetzt nicht gleich kommt noch
Backkakao dazu den könnt ihr dann sehen
aber das hier müsst ihr gerade nicht
sehen so und jetzt gebe ich das immer so
löffelweise hier in die Eier
Buttermischung habe aber hier auch schon
meine Milch die ist auch lauwarm die
habe ich kurz in die Mikrowelle gegeben
und dann immer nacheinander also
trockene Zutaten Milch immer
nacheinander damit sich das einfach
besser miteinander verbindet
[Musik]
die helle Teigmasse ist jetzt fertig
aber bei einem Marmorkuchen gibt es ja
auch ein Kakaoanteil also ein kakaoteig
und daher nehmen wir uns jetzt einfach
nach Augenmaß da muss man keine große
Wissenschaft draus machen ihr müsst da
nichts ablegen einfach nach Augenmaß ein
Drittel des Tages wegnehmen ich nehme
jetzt hier die Schüssel und spare mir
einfach das Geschirrspülen da waren ja
gerade nur die trockenen Zutaten mit
drin und dann schöpfe ich mir so ein
Drittel nach Augenmaß ab und dann wird
es zum kakaoteig indem wir natürlich
Kakao rein tun und da meine ich jetzt
nicht den trinkkakao also nicht den
Cover oder sowas mit ganz viel Zucker
drin das ist reiner Backkakao der ist
stark entölt und daher eben auch sehr
sehr trocken da gebe ich ihn jetzt nicht
so rein sondern in dem Fall einmal durch
mein Handy
und weil das dann eben auch so trocken
ist brauchen wir wieder einen Anteil an
flüssiger Zutat
und dann nehmen wir Milch so jetzt meine
[Musik]
alles im Geschirrspüler eigentlich
Schneebesen und das geht auch mit meinem
Teigschaber und verrühre das hier schön
und gibt dann auch die Milch hinzu
besser wäre auch hier wenn sie lauwarm
ist weil dann verbindet sich das besser
wenn ihr das rührt habt ihr dann schön
Kakao Teig und dann können wir auch
schon den Ofen vorheizen und unsere
Gugelhupfform bereit machen
so jetzt nehmen wir uns eine Standard
Gugelhupfform und Fetten das ein ich
nehme natürlich mein backtrennt aber die
stolz drauf muss ich echt zugeben haben
wir 11 Monate lang getüftelt weil das
ist komplett ohne Alkohol daher jetzt
auch nicht instinktiv schütteln sondern
einfach sprühen und das ist Bio finde
ich auch mega und dann habt ihr nicht
diese Alkoholfahne
es riecht noch nichts verlinke ich euch
übrigens gerne unten in die Infobox so
und als nächstes geben wir jetzt einmal
den hellen Teig rein aber nicht komplett
wir Schichten das jetzt also gehen wir
jetzt erstmal so eine feine Schicht vom
hellen Teig rein dann den kakaoteig dann
wieder hellen Teig dann wieder und wir
schließen dann ab mit dem hellen Teig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
versucht mal den kakaoteig nicht
unbedingt am äußeren Rand zu verteilen
man ist jetzt so oder so schön aussehen
aber versucht es einfach mal eher so
innen zu platzieren bzw auch wenn es
hier am inneren Kreis entlang kommt ist
das nicht schlimm aber für die Optik
habt ihr so dann außen alles schön hell
und dann ist erst im Anschnitt so dieser
Kakao Anteil zu sehen daher versuch's
einfach mal wie gesagt es sieht so oder
so schön ich schließe jetzt hier noch
mit hellen Teig ab dann werde ich das
noch so ein bisschen glatt machen
einfach damit es auch gleichmäßig
überall backt und überall gleichmäßig
gar wird und werde dann aber auch ganz
zum Schluss noch mal mit einem
Buttermesser einfach die schöne
Marmorierung machen
und dann kann er auch schon in den
Backofen unbedingt immer vorheizen den
Backofen Leute niemals in den
unvorgeheizten Backofen geben auf 180
Grad Ober- und Unterhitze und da brauche
er so 50 bis 55 Minuten
[Musik]
so die Backzeit ist um ob es dann 50
oder 55 Minuten sind das hängt von einem
Ofen ab jeder Ofen backt anders auch
wenn die Temperatur immer 180 Grad
anzeigt heißt es nicht dass es immer
exakt 180 Grad sind daher einfach mit
einem Schaschlikspieß reingehen
natürlich dann wenn ihr dann noch ein
Backprozess seid nach 50 Minuten und
wenn dann nichts dran hängen bleibt das
ist absolut nichts dann ist er fertig
aber wenn ihr merkt es noch ein bisschen
feuchter Teig dran dann darf der noch
drei vier fünf Minuten länger drin
bleiben so und am besten stürzt ihr
euren Kuchen noch warm aber nicht zu
heiß also 15 Minuten stehen lassen und
dann einfach ein abkühlgitter hier
drauflegen und dann einmal Umstürzen ein
paar mal drauf hauen und dann kommt es
eigentlich auch schon wie von alleine
runter
[Musik]
so und jetzt werden wir gut
backtrennspray drauf gegeben
juhu hübsch hübsch jetzt könnt ihr euch
noch entscheiden ob ihr dann nach dem
vollständigen Abkühlen einfach
Puderzucker drauf gibt oder noch mal
eine Schokoglasur ich muss sagen das ist
ja schon Schoko innen drin ich mache
einfach ganz klassisch ein bisschen
Puderzucker und top und dann einfach nur
richtig geilen Cappuccino dazu und den
saftigen Marmorkuchen
[Musik]
so auf mich wartet jetzt ganz viel
Geschirr ganz viel Wäsche den Boden muss
ich auch noch wischen aber zuallererst
kommt es wichtigste ich probiere meinen
saftigen Gugelhupf ich weiß ja dass er
gut schmeckt ich muss mal einmal aber
eigentlich muss ich mir dazu einen
Kaffee gönnen das mache ich gleich das
könnte ich mir gleich hm oh ich drehe
durch der so saftig einfach nur geil
Leute ultra ultra saftig und extremer
extremer Vanille Geschmack was überhaupt
nicht fehlen dafür nicht weil ich mir
vorstelle ich hätte diesen
Vanillegeschmack nicht ja saftig schön
und gut dann trinke ich mir den noch
meinen Kaffee oder so und dann dann ist
gut aber ich finde einfach gerade diese
Vanille also dieses komplette Aroma was
ich gerade durch meine ganze Nase ziehen
beim Probieren ist einfach so lecker und
der schokoladenanteil ist auch perfekt
er ist nicht zu viel er ist nicht zu
wenig und das Muster ist wunderschön
macht ihn unbedingt nach ganz dicke
Empfehlung geht raus und ansonsten
wünsche ich euch viel Spaß beim
Nachmachen und sage bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
[Musik]